One factor that makes teaching a lifelong learning
process is because in our classrooms
we have diverse students
and therefore
they also have diverse needs.
I love nothing
that our students come from different backgrounds
with different learning styles,
abilities and needs.
Therefore, Thaio
Bilamante Chersnila
must do our best to learn about their diverse needs
and adapt to these differences
so that we can provide a more inclusive
and more equitable education.
But how do we cater to our students
different learning styles and capabilities?
We can start applying differentiated instruction
such as content differentiation,
process differentiation,
assessment differentiation,
output differentiation,
flexible grouping
and scaffolding and feedback.